all right this morning we are looking at
the rise in Americans working remotely
as part of our series with LinkedIn
called work in progress what a great
name a new study from Harvard Business
School says geographic flexibility can
save money for businesses and staffers
researchers found employees who work
remotely raised revenue and productivity
and boosted their local economy LinkedIn
estimates since 2016 there has been a
78% increase in job postings that
mentioned work flexibility LinkedIn
senior editor at large Jesse temple is
here Jesse good morning good morning
so is there there's always this idea
that if you work from home you're kind
of lazy you're on the couch watching CBS
this morning or you're or you're on the
beach there's nothing wrong with
watching CBS this morning
exactly right what remote workers
they're doing when they're working
they're working yeah so what's happening
what did you guys find so what we're
finding is that people increasingly want
to be expected to be able to work from
wherever they want to work and when
we're talking about remote workers maybe
you're thinking about someone who works
from home and that's part of it but
that's not all of it increasingly people
are choosing to live in different cities
and they work in if you work in Seattle
and you live in Charlotte North Carolina
you're gonna buy a much nicer house but
yeah because the difference in the cost
of housing there sure but isn't there
some benefit in face-to-face interaction
with your colleagues and certainly with
your boss I would that would be very
hard to get promoted if you don't have
face to face interaction
how do people navigate around that well
Gail I think what you're getting at is
mentorship and relationships and just as
if you are in the office if you're
working remotely you have to build those
the thing about working remotely is you
have to work harder to do it so whether
it is getting into the office on a
quarterly basis and making sure to
schedule lunches with people to get to
know them or just scheduling a weekly
phone call with a colleague to catch up
maybe there's no work to do in building
that intangible part it's really really
necessary so why might this be good for
employers I get why employees my honor
they're you'd be laughing you know you
can hit all your personal stuff at home
as well but like if you're an employer
why well two big reasons the first is it
saves money if you're not paying for my
desk if you're not paying for my
overhead over
that's money that goes into your purse
but it saves money in another place two
employees want it it's a perk if you
offer it to them they will stay and when
they don't leave you save money on
attrition and don't you find most people
when they say they're working from home
they're really working yeah you know if
you feel bad about I would think that
you want to prove to your employer that
this really works for me and works for
you right if it doesn't work you're not
gonna get the perk at the office you're
doing stuff inside the office I mean
let's be honest that like goofing off
thing that happens at home yeah happens
at the office you drop a package in the
mail to your sister on the office's dime
it's just like it's a bad rap at home I
think you're right though you probably
would want to be more productive yes
prove to yourself you and your employer
that you can handle working from home
that this is a good good idea I think
she's helped some people make the case
to bosses today some conversation gonna
be going on Thank You Jesse Apple always
good to have you here